Hey guys! Welcome back to Middle Ground.
I'm Evan and this our illustrious editor, Brandon.
Hi! Really quick before we jump into the video,
we released another video on our second channel, Twobilee.
Which is a channel that we created for you guys
to get to know us the Jubilee team better.
This is a video pretty much about the origin story of Jubilee Media,
and it was filmed three years ago back when we were
freaking out that we received half a million subscribers.
So we've definitely come a long way and
you should definitely check it out.
Yep!
And a big thank you to Skillshare
for sponsoring this episode.
Stick around after the episode to learn how you can get
two months of Skillshare Premium for free and
hear quickly about one of my favorite classes.
But first here's the episode.
As I'm looking up I just see these three lights.
In like a triangular formation, it just moves without, you know,
any sound or anything.
Then it stops for 10 seconds or so and then just raises up
into the clouds and then just disappears.
They're real (laughs)
We have an entire galaxy just of
so many different planets and stars
The odds of us being alone in the universe are
almost non-existent.
I don't think the evidence shows that
I've had my own experience.
Yeah for the most part.
I have encountered aliens.
It's not like in person like they're hanging out like they're not
dense, like we are we are.
-We're talking about minimum of thousands if not millions or billions of light years away
so the odds that they have visited us is pretty astronomical that they probably didn't and may not visit us for millions of years.
I think it's pretty exciting
unless you're one of those people that's getting visited at three in the morning alone in your bedroom and getting walked out to some
craft for sexual experimentation.
My name is Greg Carlwood. I host a podcast called
Higher Side Chats in the Conspiracy.
Paranormal space has been doing it for 10 years.
So I've heard a lot of interesting stories.
I'm Luke Nyas. I'm an I.T. specialist and I've also
had my own experience, which is kind of crazy. Yeah.
Hi, I'm Lauren. I have a blog called starseedhotspot.com
I'm someone who would identify as a starseed and
have had a lot of different...
spiritual
and paranormal experiences.
Hi, my name's Linet,
I'm an actress, and I'm spiritually aware of myself, and
I believe that, you know, aliens are real.
I'm Dominic Andre.
I am actually a mental health therapist and a influencer.
But um,
I've been in love with science since I was a kid,
published by NASA, and I'm pretty much
an amateur astronomer.
(I am) Spencer Marks.
The author of the sci-fi book "Living History"
and also a senior investigator with
the Center for Inquiry Investigations Group.
We investigate claims of the paranormal.
Yeah, oh.
Welcome!
Hello!
Actually, yeah, uh, yeah I've seen one (Alien/UFO)
It was about 10 years ago,
Um, just right before I graduated high school and as I'm
looking up, I just see...
these three lights,
in like a triangular formation.
There was no "body" to it, just the three lights.
And they were like flickering, almost like
on fire or something like that.
I look at my buddy and I-
I say, "Are you seeing this?"
And he sees it and yeah,
It just it just moves without...
you know, any sound or anything, just quiet for about a minute.
Then it stops for...
10 seconds or so.
And then (it) just raises up into the clouds and then
just disappears.
Well, this is 10 years ago. So it's like,
Drones weren't really a big thing, you know.
I've never seen a plane that could hover, or at least
hover, and then not make a bunch of noise.
So it's just, it's a-
It's something I can't explain, honestly.
So for me,
as someone who is
a clairvoyant,
I'll see dimensional, like overlapping
of things.
Especially going through what's called
the Kundalini awakening.
Which was really intense, and I had a lot of different types of contact
with like aliens, through like astral projection
as well like I've-
I've left my body, seen my body laying there,
and went and visited other dimensions.
Been on spacecrafts and like, seen different spacecrafts.
These are things that like, I can't explain and
they weren't dreams.
-For me as an amateur astronomer,
I do see UFOs. But to clarify that,
UFO stands for unidentified flying objects.
So for me, yes, I do see things that-
I don't know what they are.
But my immediate conclusion isn't aliens
or intelligent life.
My immediate conclusion is:
What can I scientifically understand, you know?
We thought thunder was gods, and now we
would easily explain it to not being gods.
People will get confused,
they assimilate or they, you know,
make UFO and aliens one (the same).
And I'm like, that's not the same thing!
Lauren: That's a good point.
It would be disingenuous to say I've ever seen
one first hand, but because of what I do,
I've had plumbers come to the house.
They're like, "oh, what do you do?"
"I host a conspiracy podcast."
Well let me tell you something, you know,
my uncle is a pilot, and he would never tell his superiors this,
but he's seen this and this and even the,
U.S. Navy has released footage of UFOs and said,
"Yeah, these crafts are real, and we don't know what they are."
Just a couple years ago, It was in the New York Times! certainly
Certainly, I've seen it, I've looked (it) up and said,
"Oh, I don't know what that is."
But I never once assumed that to be an alien spacecraft.
I actually (I) am also a private pilot. So I've-
I know how to identify aircraft visually,
from the lighting pattern.
I'm also an amateur astronomer and, you know,
I looked up a thousand times through a telescope and
You can see, like some people might think that object moves so fast,
It was bright, and you know, was that a-
a UFO?
Well, I know it's a satellite. So, I'm not worried about those things.
There's a lot of people who say,
"I've seen aliens. I've seen UFOs."
It's interesting that the aliens have headlights.
- You don't want to crash in the ground!
- I think, I think that we we don't even need those now. I mean,
you know, like, we can use the technology...
So it's interesting that we always use like human-like objects
to explain-
There's like a catch-all, you know what I mean?
Because it's like you said, oh they have headlights.
Well, maybe yeah, maybe they have lights, but maybe it's
not so they can see.
There could be a different purpose for it.
You know what I mean?
Luke: I'm not one...
to be a fiber, you know? It's like,
If I believe in something,
I-I'm not afraid to say it.
Even if people might think I'm crazy or whatever.
Because it's just something that's so weird
and different that....
I mean, why would you make that up?
This galaxy, this universe is so vast and wide.
To believe that they aren't here now, it's kind of-
dumb, in my opinion
-Some kind of multi-dimensional thing. I mean,
Someone's flying all those crafts that people see out there!
-Right.
-I've never seen any, that I know of.
But I have interviewed a lot of researchers who have,
heard from people within the government,
within the Department of Defense that have said,
That they are pretty confident that that's a reality and that the-
Black budget goes to trying to keep
some kind of tabs on-
this activity.
-I have read some stuff about people being abducted,
into government facilities, Area 51 things like that.
If we're talking about like the traditional sense
of like, an alien?
They work with our government.
They keep this matrix operating, you know, and
As someone who identifies as a starseed, I mean like,
Technically, I'm an alien that incarnated here.
-I guess I interpret it as living among us. I think of like,
The reptilians where, you know,
They're in disguise and they're...
assimilating into-
our society,
where you could be an alien and you're just not saying it,
You know what mean?
-I really don't (Laughs)
-I don't know if you see them in the line at Starbucks,
But I do think for there to be physical...
experiences, they're just sharing the planet with us.
-I just find the notion pretty far-fetched.
I mean why the secrecy?
If they want to learn from us? If we want to learn about them? They're-
Why wouldn't they just step forward and say,
"Here we are!"
-I think we all obviously believe aliens do exist here, or statistically,
which is fine.
But to say that, that they traveled here is another thing,
Because like, with the Roswell crash,
(It's) very, very unlikely to see...
someone be able to do that 10,000 years across the entire universe,
and then crash immediately when we get here.
-Well, plus you look at the debris. I mean,
They have pictures of the debris.
It's, like literally, Balsa wood and you know, Mylar!
-Pictures THEY showed you!
-But the point is, there's not enough physical (evidence).
If you're in a spaceship, it's not going to be 3 pounds of debris.
-I've read a lot of books about the chain of custody
of that material.
There's thousands of people who've had experiences,
There's uh, dozens and dozens of crash stories
that are Beyond Roswell.
-Do you think that the person writing the book has
an incentive, financially, to write a book?
-Yes. But is a doctor less good because
he makes money being a doctor?
Aliens is kind of a loaded term. I mean,
I think of non-human intelligences',
which could be things people experience on psychedelics?
I woke up one day, a complete material atheist.
Some friends convinced me to try Salvia Divinorum and then,
It was kind of, like, an instantaneous...
out of body experience.
And then that felt entirely natural.
It felt more normal than waking life.
And then there-there was a male and a female...
entity of some kind.
They spoke to me. They're like,
"Wow, we're surprised you're here!" I'm, like,
"I'm surprised that I'm here!"
And one was more cynical about,
..the fact that I wouldn't be there long, and the other one was just
more excited about (myself) being there at all.
And the one was like, "Well, why?"
"Why are you even talking to this guy? He's going to be gone!"
"He's going to be gone in just a few minutes." And the other was like,
"But he's here now!"
I'm convinced there's intelligence out there that
are non-human, that we can interact with, but,
That (experience) kind-of changed my life actually.
-I think the data for UFOs and non-human intelligence is pretty strong.
I think you...
have to really dive into it, because
It's not being presented on the news.
But when you look at it, there's no shortage of really
credible sources that have seen some pretty incredible things.
Paul Hellyer is the ex-defense minister of Canada, and he says,
"Hey, there's these crafts flying over and they're shooting
our nuclear facilities with some kind of beam and disabling them."
I mean, that's a fairly credible source.
-Right. Well, look, anecdotal evidence is some evidence, but
it's not strong evidence.
As far as physical evidence,
that's where we fall short.
-I would disagree with that. Have you ever tried a psychedelic compound?
-I have not
-I mean hey, we can figure this out pretty quick!
You do it, and then you tell me it wasn't real.
-Well, so you're saying that something you take
is gonna create an external difference?
We can't look at that as evidence, any more than we can say,
"I dreamt something."
-It widens perceptions of consciousness...
-But that's from your brain!
Lauren: But that's like a hallucination.
That's not really expanding consciousness.
Like you're talking about like hallucinating.
-Well what's the difference?
-So, I think science is also based on perception.
You're talking about the brain, and the brain being powerful.
But so is our heart center, which science can prove,
has its own energy field around it.
And it's much stronger than our brain.
So the point that I want to make is like,
Science is based on perception.
It's a bunch of people perceiving studies a certain way, right?
But so is spirituality.
-The the difference (is that) science is not that,
five different scientists perceive something differently
or in the same way.
They look at evidence and if that evidence guides them and
points them toward a particular direction, and it's repeatable,
and it's falsifiable,
We tend to say, well,
That's what reality tends to be, or seems to be.
Lauren: But that's reality based on your perception.
-No, it's not a perception.
- (Laughs) It is! Everything is perception!
-We're probably misinformed about a lot of stuff.
But for the other side to say, "you guys are misinformed",
I think is just as ridiculous, because I think...
-That's like what I meant, honestly, is like we all have our
own truth, and that's relative to you and....
It's valid, regardless.
- And I think that can be true for people, and I think
it's hard because I could show you an expert.
(But) it's meaningless to you.
But, you could show me your expert and, this is the right one.
And so, it's interesting because I work with a lot of Muslims,
They're saying, "you know I've spoken to my god."
Then a Christian says, "The Muslim's god is wrong, but I've spoken to my god."
Hindu says,
"You know I've actually recognized and remembered my
past life, and I can name it down to a T."
And so if we get to that point, I think everyone would
then just be right, and we know there would be no actual unifying reality.
But the scientific community is saying we want to create
a unified reality between each other, so we can progress,
in our own way.
And that's why science we would never say there
aren't aliens or are aliens, you know?
You're saying....
aliens, you know, "There was a crash."
We would say "There could be, but.."
- Fair
-And we don't know, and right now it's leaning this way.
So misinformation is different. It's more just about...
Kind-of like hardheadedness on that.
-I think it's more close-mindedness to say...
Yours' a whole kind of organization is is not to be
malicious in debunking things but that that is your goal,
is-is to...
Disprove something.
-No, that's not at all. It's absolutely not true.
-Well you-you...
-No. Our organization looks it's evidence for things that we ask others
They have a claim of a paranormal activity, great!
Show it to us!
Show us the evidence!
We don't do anything to debunk them. We simply-
Lauren: I feel that's really limiting though.
-No, but-but the point is that's not limiting if-
Lauren: That's the thing, the with misinformation. I just feel like it's just-
limiting instead of missing-
-Well, the purpose is to find the truth. To find the truth and-
-What do you say to the U.S. Navy who has come out and said
there are unidentified flying crafts that defy physics.
We don't know what they are.
Is that a credible source to you?
-We don't know our physics. We're learning our physics.
-Well, I agree with that. I think that's why there's a lot of suppression in this area
because it unlocks hidden technology.
-But the U.S. Navy is saying "We don't know what it is." That's the point.
-There's so many tapes that you see from like the air force,
where you see these flying objects.
-And that's the same thing of saying, you know, 5000 years ago...
"That's thunder! You guys saw that thunder. It's god."
We're just saying we don't know, and to jump to conclusion...
Lauren: But jumping to conclusion is kind of far-fetched.
(Laughter)
-That's the good stuff!
-You asked for this
-Is this the content you want?
-I am completely on the side of science and evidence.
I investigate claims of the paranormal with a group called
The Center for Inquiry Investigations Group and,
We have not found any evidence whatsoever,  of any
sort of paranormal activity, or aliens, or any of that sort of thing.
And we've looked.
I have been on the show before, yes.
In the "Flat Earth" episode.
It was a great experience.
My only comment was that we presented a lot of
science, and all of that was edited out.
We sort of ended up with interesting sound bites,
but not so much of the science.
If you try to store military facilities,
you're going to have a bad time.
-Exactly!
-If they can wipe people's memories that have been
working there for 20 years like,
(Snaps)
Like that! Then...
What could they do to people that are trying to storm
a government facility?
-Uh, mow em down? (Laughs) I mean,
That's literally it! I mean,
I know it- I think it started as just like a kind of a joke,
Facebook group or something like that...
which is like, okay, that's kind of funny.
But the fact that there is kind of a-
Somewhat of a consensus where at least with skeptics,
that people who do believe in aliens are
somewhat crazy or weird, you know what I mean?
Like something's a little off with them.
So it was bad,
not only for people in general,
but also believers in UFOs and aliens, in general.
-I definitely don't believe it was necessarily a bad idea.
I feel like it put pressure on the government to be like,
"Hey, there are a lot of people who are curious
about what you're doing." and if you have a
whole facility of just like, secrets,
You can't help but explore that curiosity and see for yourself.
-And I definitely agree with that.
But it wasn't like we had a group of, you know,
Scientists, and-and well-to-do people that would be,
I guess, more respected.
It was just a bunch of kids making jokes about clapping
alien cheeks, you know what I mean?
It's just like, there was there was no seriousness behind it.
-Like the way it was constructed (organized).
-Yeah
-I feel like religion or science can be kind of limited and boxed.
I have a Catholic background,
So in my family,
aliens aren't real.
It's just human beings.
So growing up in that kind of environment,
I should have a different opinion from what I have now.
-You said humans, right? Okay.
Just clarifying.
I grew up as a Catholic and to now, you know,
I've transitioned to being a Christian and all of that.
So I do believe in God.
I do believe that He created us, and I also believe
He created everything else the: planet, uh,
nature, the galaxy
and beyond.
- If the question was "Were we made by aliens?" I might not have stepped forward,
but higher power is a wider umbrella.
We're clearly very different from every other thing on this planet
-Right
- And I think there was some intervention at some point
that might have facilitated that.
Terence Mckenna thought it was mushrooms that-
(That) we did psychedelic mushrooms, and that facilitated a
evolution of consciousness.
And mushroom spores can survive in space too, so,
maybe they are the aliens that helped us get
to where we are right now.
-So we are for sure an evolutionary accident, I mean,
We don't know why-
we develop these big brains, but we did.
I mean, we've only been around kind of a couple hundred thousand years.
Yeah, actually, kind-of a piggyback off of that where,
us as animals, because that's basically what we are,
We're just really smart animals, you know,
It's just we took a path...
of how we evolve to where we are today, you know,
and like you said with the the mushrooms possibly being part (playing a part)
That's that would be part of the evolution of what we are.
-It does change brain chemistry, so let's say that mushrooms-
-It does but that would be more toward a Lamarckian evolution,
as opposed to a Darwinian evolution because,
Lamarck thought that, if you just did a pressure, if you did forces,
Then that would change different
generations and,
We're pretty sure that doesn't happen.
I mean many many generations of Jews have been circumcising their babies and yet,
every baby has been born with a foreskin after that.
So, it's sort of not something you can force, apparently.
-But when we talked about higher power, I don't know you well enough,
we just met but I guarantee, he wouldn't be past saying,
"Yes aliens could have made us." You know?
There could be civilizations that are tens of thousands of years ahead of us,
They could've came in here, and altered things,
that is 100% a possibility.
But possibility and probability are two different things,
and I think that's really important 'cause I can sit here all day and tell you
"Yes, we could all be in a simulation."
That is in-statistically possible.
But statistically possible, it's not how we all operate our lives.
We use statistics in everyday life.
And I think that's really important to not let it go when it comes to everything else,
when it comes to spiritual issues or evolution, and to say,
" Although I operate my entire life off statistics, I'm not going to do it here."
-I think there is some science that like,
indicates like life on other planets, or like,
Going back to ancient civilizations, there is proof that,
they believed in aliens.
But for me personally, I would say it's very spiritual-based.
-It wouldn't make sense for me to not step forward,
considering the fact that I identify as a starseed.
So, it's just something that you awaken to your own...
divinity, and it's very personal to you.
And I think we're all in different paths and
everyone's valid in their own way but-
-Absolutely! And when you have an experience with it,
It's about it's verified. It's validated, but until you do,
It's not there!
- It fascinates me, you know, I've watched many documentaries,
many specials and things like that regarding this topic,
But it's not like I live and breathe it.
-You know, i'm not going to dwell on it til it happens,
I'm not going to worry about it too much.
I'd love to be the first guy, to you know,
see the craft land, go up,
Introduce myself, you know, get some alien technology,
take my photos with my iPhone up close.
You know selfies. I mean, I would love to do that.
- When you're ready.
-Yeah. Right, exactly.
Ayahuasca is a facilitator of contact made from two plants in the Amazon-
-I've had a friend do it, and he basically said that from that,
he found Hinduism, and he knows to be sure that
Reincarnation is real. Aliens aren't.
It's all on Earth.
So that's why it's interesting because it's like,
Would you disagree with his statement that there are no other aliens? It's just Hinduism.
And why would his trip be different than yours? And non-
-Well, I just consider the umbrella of aliens to be
more like non-human intelligence(s), whether it's multi-dimensional,
something people called spirits, or angels, or aliens.
It doesn't seem like his experience necessarily would devalue that.
He might have a different box or label.
I normally tell everyone I don't have beliefs. It's all based off statistics.
I'm not here to say
100% there are aliens, just statistically there are.
So I'm here to always just make the boundary between people who say,
"100% there are aliens!"
And the people who say, "100% there aren't aliens."
And I don't think either of those are correct.
But we have to look at it as a number situation, and
I think that's very important because we can't be using our emotion,
Or our religion, to determine whether there are aliens or not.
-To me, it unlocked an entire dimension of reality
that I was denying beforehand.
You know? A spiritual dimension of consciousness.
Once you take these compounds, you can experience things beyond yourself,
that science is going to have a tough time with,
because science is in this box of the material world.
-There's so many things in this world that we-we don't
have any information on, so.
Almost kind-of narcissistic in effect, to say
we're the only intelligent beings that live in this entire known universe.
So yeah. No, I think, uh,
Believe what you want, but aliens are real.
-I definitely agree with what you were saying.
There's just too many things in this world to just have one single (idea)-
"This is it."
"This is the truth." idea.
-Before my spiritual awakening,
I was just like you guys. 100% and I was actually atheist.
Someone like me who went through a spiritual awakening,
And someone who is a starseed, and just being like,
"Okay, who am I? I'm not from here." I could speak
this other language, like I can do these things that like,
don't make any sense.
And having the kind of experiences that I've had, it's something that...
Science can't explain to me.
And so I feel like,
just operating from a science base is kind-of limiting yourself.
-Yeah, and I think the...
misconception is a lot of people think that science is
nothing more than some weird collection of facts and figures,
it's not that at all.
It's a methodology, by which you explore the world, explore the universe, but
To give you an idea of how vast the universe is,
you could take the smallest grain of dust,
paint it blue,
go out to the middle of the pacific ocean and throw it in there, and a year later,
Tell your friend to go find that grain of dust.
That would be much easier to find,
than define the earth in this universe, if you didn't know where to look for the earth.
I mean we are so small and insignificant compared to a
grain of dust in the Pacific Ocean.
-I think we all kind of agree aliens probably do exist.
There's a great chance for me- 99.99% chance here.
It's just a fine line when we talk about,
You know psychedelics or inner, you know, realities,
because I think then we have to credit people with schizophrenia,
we have to credit people with all types of disorders,
to then not downplay what they believe, and what they see
And they see their mother walking in front of them,
and they see the ants that actually evolve into humans in front of them and,
So I think it's hard to do that, because I think if we go down that realm(s),
then we can't discredit them either,
not to say we can't, but it would put us down that realm where we have to credit all of them.
And so it's really important that for me is yes, we can go down that road
but I think that road didn't lead us to cars,
hospitals, different things like that.
(Applause)
-Thanks guys
-Yeah, thank you.
-Yeah, it's great meeting all of you.
-Yes, you too. Wonderful.
Wow, that was a trip.
Have you ever been in contact with an alien?
-I have not
I-I am pretty sure I believe in aliens.
-Hmmm hmm
Elon musk is an alien
-Oh, yeah
That was a prompt that we initially were gonna have in the video
and we ended up not asking it, for time.
I wish we had included that one.
I haven't met him though. So I still have not contacted an alien.
A big thank you to Skillshare for sponsoring this episode.
For those of you who don't know,
Skillshare is an online learning community where creative and
curious people can come together to try new things, gain new skills.
A class that I really like is called
"Real Productivity: How to Build Habits that last" by
author and fellow YouTuber, Thomas Frank
So, I like the class because the first thing he hits you with is the idea that
perfect is the enemy of good, and that's something we talk a lot about at Jubilee.
We all want to do great work. We all want to make something perfect.
But if we really just focus on that end goal, it's really hard to start.
So with that said, the first 1000 subscribers who click on the link in the description below
will get a 2 month free-trial of Skillshare Premium.
And as always,
-Stay safe!
-And like, comment and subscribe!
-Both of those things!
-Peace out earthlings! Bye!